this is a clock and this is a clock and
this is a clock and every one of these
clocks is an inventive Journey this
clock walks over 3 000 miles a year
it'll walk back and forth once a minute
so if I put it on Interstate 80 headed
west it would be out in San Francisco by
the end of the year meet Rick Stanley he
makes clocks using everything from
bottles to bicycles dominoes and even
liquid each one is completely unique and
totally accurate even when we're on
vacation somewhere I think of different
clocks to make I could not see myself
doing anything other than clocks
there's five elements of a clock energy
gearing escapement control and
indication energy this is a rock here we
have gearing which slows down the speed
for the hands we have an escapement
which starts and stops the movement here
we have a pendulum which is what
determines how fast the escapement is
moving and we have a dial to read the
actual time from this is a walking clock
when it gets to this end here it will
hit the stop sign which will increment
to the next minute all this metal here I
hand bent and welded so that the
bearings would be at these exact spots
the inspiration from this clock came
from a machine that was used for testing
shoes because everything I see is a
clock all I have to do is figure out how
to take that concept and roll it into a
clock this is the Domino clock there's a
small solenoid under there that will
push the Domino up every minute on the
hour I carved my daughter's hand here
this will push out push all the dominoes
down and the last one will hit the
counter which will move over to the next
hour
Rick's lifelong study of clocks puts the
concept of time into a unique
perspective
I think time has always been something
that's been important to people you look
even prehistoric people look at the
stars some people are always concerned
about they need to do this they need to
do that I don't I kind of flow with the
time do you like daylight savings time
yeah no I don't like daylight savings
time it takes me weeks to change all the
clocks back to how they're supposed to
be this is a bottle clock
the motor turns one revolution a minute
which is the second hand the bottles
mesh with one another there's 12 bottles
here and 24 here so this has to go
around twice for this to go around once
this is 30 bottles to 12 36 bottles to
12 and 48 bottles to 12. that's 1 60th
the speed here than it was where it
started then it continues on this way
and drops it another 1 12 of opening on
the bottles is not consistent each bolt
had to be turned to a different diameter
this is 300 bottles 300 bolts we had to
turn each one was a different size to
get this clock to be built this is my
fluid clock
on the hour the minutes drain out and
the hours fill it's the only 3D clock I
know of normally clocks just have a dial
this one whichever direction you walk at
it you can tell the time there's pumps
down here that provide oil for the hour
and the minute a small timer
microprocessor turns the pumps on and
off
I definitely have a very childlike
curiosity I think everybody should when
I was little I mean like four or five
years old I took clocks apart I didn't
put them together which was a problem
for my parents but I did try to build
stuff over the years that were
interesting solving problems as
staggering as Rick's finish clocks are
he always has something in the works
that he's never done before this is my
prototype area where I go from creating
an idea to actually building it some of
these work quite well some of them are
still in the refinement stage I'll come
up with different designs this one in
particular is the timber frame clock
with a different size gears that are
used on that here's the Chimes and
here's a detail of the escapement that
we used
this prototype I call time traveler
every hour one clock will come out
this clock operates off of pneumatics
and it has air cylinders that will
extend it out lift up the lid the timing
comes off of a little microprocessor
this is probably about eight months work
I'm going to build another two more
sections on this for the full 12 hours
future projects these cams here will
lift mannequin hands bringing balls up
to a new elevation
so to actually come up with the concept
usually takes less than a day then it
takes a couple weeks to design if
there's electronic parts order those and
then it usually takes maybe eight months
to a year to actually construct the
clock this clock uses ball bearings the
wonderful feature about these versus a
regular gear is that you can go at
different angles it has a motor here
which Powers the second hand which comes
through the clock this will power the
minute hand here and then it's further
reduced down in speed to power up the
hour hand while clocks are Rick's main
medium his love of invention is evident
throughout his space this is a feather
duster I made for cleaning the barn I
know this only cleans one foot but I
really like the unique idea of having an
arm that would clean even a small
portion of the barn
here we are in the cafeteria
this is where the cat has her feeder she
has a chip it'll be sensed right here
and it's only her that will be able to
eat the food and it'll come down it'll
stay down for three minutes and then
it'll return on uh well let me show you
this my granddaughter's favorite song
and she'll be coming around the mountain
a friend said to me I can't believe
you'd spend all this time for a
two-year-old she's not two she's two and
a half and she'll correct me every time
now we'll go over into the wood shop
first thing I usually do is I will start
my music
this is a wonderful space I have it has
high ceilings it's easy to move wood
around here I have all the tools that I
feel I need for most of my projects
we'll go over to the band saw here it's
a very nice bandsaw built in the late
1800s the one problem I had was lighting
so I built this light that lowers down
from the ceiling I'm sorry I build a
Pneumatic air cylinder the lower light
down to give me the light I need when
I'm building a clock I will spend hours
at this band saw cutting out different
pieces
here's another prototype I made it's a
Transformer clock I love Transformers
where it'll take one object and turn it
into something completely different I
built this as a grandfather clock that
will turn into a desk and still keep the
time
this uses Arduino or microprocessor set
up that the motors will work at the
proper timing this probably has over a
thousand hours working and reworking to
get it into the state it's probably
still six months or a year away from
becoming something that would be worth
putting in a house the surfaces need to
be all beautiful not how they are now
Rick loves his time in his Workshop but
for him a project isn't complete when it
works it requires a bit more I'm elated
when it works but it doesn't stop there
I need to have somebody else a family
member or somebody that stops by and I
like to show it to them and say look at
this what do you think because I get
self-gratification but I even get more
gratification seeing other people's
faces light up